the eu haven't exactly covered
themselves in glory this last week have
they
no they haven't at all and i think the
the only good thing is the speed in
which they
reversed their their wrong decision to
look at invoking
article 16 of the treaty look we all
want to see the free flow of goods both
between the republic
of ireland and northern ireland also
between great britain and northern
ireland and that is absolutely essential
for the people of northern ireland and
any attempt to use northern ireland as a
political football
is absolutely wrong and so i'm pleased
that decision has now been reversed
if you look at the vaccination rate the
uk is really storming ahead of all the
other countries
in the eu um you of course campaign to
remain but
many people will see this as a
vindication i guess for why they
supported brexit but
we're more nimble less bogged down with
bureaucracy outside of the eu has the
last week been a big
advertisement for leaving
i think that um we all in our country
feel immense pride of our scientists our
universities
our companies producing the vaccines and
also our
nhs which has done a fantastic job in
distributing the the vaccine over the
last weeks 2.2 million people
in the last week and i believe that our
nhs inside or outside the european union
is our greatest asset as a country and
we're seeing that
with the distribution of of the vaccine
now
do you accept then that labour was wrong
to call for the uk to join the eu's
vaccine program last summer
look i mean the uk has done a fantastic
job in procuring vaccines and i give
credit to the government
uh in doing that the use of the nhs
rather than outsourcing it to circo and
other private companies
has clearly been the right approach as
has
procuring that the vaccine in advance
from so many uh different companies
but in the end we're only going to
succeed in defeating this virus
if all countries have access to the
vaccines because otherwise it will just
mutate and come back here
in a different form so look vaccine
nationalism whether it's from the eu or
anyone else
i think is totally counterproductive
because in the end we've got to ensure
that people especially vulnerable people
around the world it get the
um the vaccine so that we can protect
ourselves at home
as well as protecting people around the
globe so you think that at some point
we should look to give some of our
vaccine supply elsewhere at what point
do you think we should do that and who
do you think we should prioritize
look at the moment we haven't even
vaccinated the most vulnerable
here at home so this is not the right
time to be um
looking to to to shift our vaccines
here in britain to other countries
around the world
but i hope in time that we'll be able to
do more to share as we already have
provided aid to some of the poorest
countries
in the in the world but i think most
crucially
we need to boost production of the
different vaccines around the world
and we're playing our part with the
production of the vaccine in
in the uk and that is fantastic but we
need to help other parts of the world
whether in europe
or around the globe also produce the
vaccine to get it to their people and
that's a part that the uk can play in
ensuring
that the world has access to this
vaccine it's in our national interest
here at home as well as being the right
thing to do
you've acknowledged of course the
success of the uk's vaccine
uh program you've been gracious enough
to give the government a bit of credit
for that as well
and but in the past you have been quite
critical of kate bingham the chair of
the vaccine task force in november for
example you said
it's vital that the government
immediately show how they've managed any
real or perceived conflict of interest
with this appointment
otherwise this appears to be another in
a string of government appointments and
contracts
handed to friends without due process
if all john boris johnson's friends are
as effective as kate bingham should they
more of them get jobs
i didn't hear all of that question but i
think it is right that as an opposition
party
we challenge the government where they
get it wrong but also
give praise where things have gone well
and it is absolutely the case
that the uk government but also working
with our scientists our universities our
businesses but also crucially with our
nhs have been distributing
the vaccine through gp surgeries and
these huge vaccine centers
it has been a success and we are all
proud of that
as a country but there have been parts
of the response to this virus
that haven't gone so well and it's right
to call that out as well so for example
handing over test and trace to private
companies
that held us back in our fight against
the virus
the the success of the distribution of
the vaccine shows
that actually when you work with our
local communities and with our nhs
you're going to be a lot more successful
than when you privatize and outsource
to uh to different companies like circo
and switzerland and the rest and so
i think that the vaccine has shown that
actually when you work with the fabric
of our communities and our public
services
you can get on top of this virus and
it's a shame the government didn't do
that with things like test and trace
earlier on in the process and i would
say to the government it's not too late
to change the course on test and trace
because i believe it would work a lot
better
if we work more closely with the nhs and
with our local
communities and councils in a test and
trace model
rather than through these big
outsourcing companies um
i'm keen to talk a little bit about
vaccine priority and we heard from tony
blair just before you who was saying
that's a case that teachers should be
moved up the list i know it's something
that labour has called for as well
at the same time though the reason that
the joint committee of vaccine and
immunization has recommended
people are in the order they are is
because the next group to be vaccinated
those between 50 and 70 represent
11 of deaths i mean that's why they've
been
prioritized so if you move teachers and
as you say lots of key workers in
critical professions swell up the list
you could be costing lives
there's two things um here first of all
um it's about the capacity to get this
vaccine to people and then second it's
about uh
who comes in at what stage the success
in the rollout of the vaccine
is fantastic and 2.2 million people were
vaccinated last week
that's an increase of 600 000 on the
week before
so we know that we are ramping up the
distribution production
of this vaccine and so what we can do
now
is to bring more people in and in a
couple of weeks time
the most vulnerable people would have
been vaccinated
and that is fantastic so now let's use
this opportunity in the next couple of
weeks to think about the next stage
of the rollout of this vaccine and we
know
that some people because of the work
that they do are more exposed to the
virus
if you are lucky enough to be able to
work from home you've got a car
and when you do need to get out then you
are less at risk to being exposed to the
vaccine than if say for example
you're a bus driver or a taxi driver or
you work in a supermarket
or you work on the front line in the
police if you work in those jobs
you are more exposed to the virus and so
what labor is saying
is can the jcbi the joint committee on
vaccines and immunizations
look at how we can ensure that those
people are most exposed to the virus
get access to it at a bit of an earlier
stage i think that is the right thing to
do
there's another thing as well and that's
around our schools
older people of course are more likely
to get this virus
and to get it seriously but young people
are also paying a huge price
for the coronavirus pandemic for the
best part of a year
our kids are going to be out of school
and that
that is really tough i mean it's tough
for the kids tough for their mental
health tough for their educational
entertainment
it's tough for parents i've got five and
seven-year-olds so i know all about this
to be able to hold down a job and also
teach your kids at
home we want our kids back to school and
that's what the government say
as well absolutely upset accept the the
impact
of school closures we'll be talking to a
head teacher on the programme
later about this and it's something that
you know we do feel very strongly about
too
and there are difficult arguments on all
sides but at the same time
labor has consistently criticized the
government for not following
the science by saying that the jcvi
should
their advice should effectively be
overridden isn't that exactly what
labour is doing too
no that's not what we're saying so
people let me finish my point about
schools
the governments say that school's a
priority but i don't see any evidence of
that because there's no plan
the government give arbitrary dates with
no plan of how to get there
what labour are saying is that the jcvi
should look at the prioritization and
should look at bringing more people in
as the distribution at the
prioritization aren't they they are
already looking
i've spoken to people on the jcb they
are looking at the next stage of the
prioritization what you're calling for
is for the current prioritization to be
changed so that
is override overriding the scientific
advice
sophie what we're calling um on is the
jcvi to look at the most recent data
including from the office of national
statistics
which has just published data looking at
different occupational exposure to the
virus and
suggesting for example that security
guards that transport workers
are more at risk of coming into contact
with the virus so we're asking the jcvi
to look at the most recent evidence
and to see whether there's more that can
be done to ensure that those people
in front line roles who have come into
contact with many many people every day
are being able to get the vaccine
because it seems to me
that we are a huge amount to our key
workers who have kept our economy and
our society going during this
long and difficult year and if there's
more that we can do to ensure that they
are protected
so they can go out and do their work
without the fear
that they face every single day when
they go to work of contracting the vice
and taking it home to their families
that we can allay some of that so we're
asking the jcvi to look at the evidence
and to see whether given the the ramp
out
the the ramp up of the production and
the distribution of this faction is
going so well whether we can bring more
people in
at an earlier stage to protect them i